i fluctuate a lot with my weight selena
gomez gets real about her weight and
sometimes feeling insecure
i feel like i'm able to be heard in a
new video with vogue selena breaks down
15 of her best style moments from 2007
to now
and sharing how she felt wearing this
outfit she wore to the met gala in 2015.
and i remember this night specifically i
didn't
feel good about my body so what was
really
amazing was that i actually got a chance
to work on the dress
that fit my body the singer also reveals
that this look is when she realized she
didn't have to try to fit in to a
certain standard
that was one of the moments where i was
like i don't have to be
that 19 year old body shape anymore
because i'm not
selena also credits her style team for
always making her feel comfortable
especially when she rocked this ensemble
for the dead don't die premiere in 2019.
i think it was iconic so this was also a
moment in my life where
i had fluctuated in weight and
i'm very honest with the people on my
team so
i didn't want to wear anything tight and
then i tried this dress on and
i felt so beautiful the actress also
told us what she really loved most about
the outfit
it definitely highlighted this area a
lot um
but it was so i felt like a barbie doll
the photo of the look also brought back
memories from when she shot the movie
the dead don't die and what it was like
working with bill murray
i've been telling you this is all gonna
end badly
well that's unfortunate making this
movie was a riot it was so fun
bill murray was like ugh i loved him so
much he called me gomez
had no idea who i was the entire shoot
it was
awesome and speaking of other celebs
selena opened up about this 2016 look
from her revival tour
revealing that britney spears's outfit
from the music video toxic
was the inspiration behind the costume
i'm not gonna lie britney spears
inspired it from toxic so i wanted to
find a moment where
you know that could kind of have its
place still have the outfit
and that wasn't the first time selena
paid homage to brittany last month the
former disney queen shared this video of
herself as a kid
belting out the britney classic don't go
knocking on my door
writing the caption the hustle was real
[Music]
britney even commented on the post
writing this is the most adorable thing
i've ever seen
it's really beautiful as for the britney
inspired outfit
it reminded selena that touring can be a
lot at times she canceled the revival
tour midway through
due to anxiety and depression i tend to
just
get into a place where i'm not filling
myself
up with self-love so how am i going to
give it to
all these people but i every moment of
it if you put me on a stage right now
it is the best feeling in the whole
world in 2017 selena opened up to et
about evolving in music
and life i like to choose to live my
life in a way where
i want to be weight free and i know
that's impossible to do because i have a
million on me right now but i
and everybody does but i think it is
important to to kind of go through
your life the way you want and i like to
to come
at things with my best